grace helbig here your favorite
emotionally distant internet personality
no time name is very subjective no no no
this is different now it is
back-to-school season I'm 32 years old
I'm 10 years out of college and college
is four years out of high school
14 years out of high school which makes
me the perfect person to review weird
ACTA school supplies so when I went back
to school it was a big deal to go back
to school shopping my first encounter
with artificial intelligence was my mom
allowing me to buy mechanical pencils so
I'm one that was on the other day and I
ordered some back-to-school supplies
that Amazon told me were trendy and
popular but we're obviously things that
I did not have the opportunity of owning
when I went back to school so we're
gonna review them today right now why
not gugus got to this one whenever I get
a package delivered and like thrown over
my fence because my dog dragon is
defending the castle she likes to
completely bite it open just to make
sure it's safe I remember some of the
things I bought I forget some of the
things I bought so let's review some
weird wacky cute quaint back-to-school
supplies
let's start with this one that is 30%
open already
Oh booth not only bit through the outer
plastic she fully bit cruder in this
plastic thank you
I Amazon search like funny school
supplies and this was one of them that
came up so this was a generic Gumby kind
of character tape dispenser here's where
the tape gets dispensed it gets caught
at his toes but he's also oh he sounds a
mid bowel movement and the way that they
hadn't set up it looks like he's
screaming but no it's not screaming a
perfect place to rest a pencil oh my god
I mean this is how I feel on a toilet
super vulnerable yeah you can okay the
last thing I want on the toilet is more
jobs you're trying to pass chemistry on
a BM you don't need other
responsibilities you want to be able to
have a healthy separation of your
schoolwork your your job and your mental
and physical well-being and if we can
see by this character you can't do it
all give this thing a break but the
other cute thing is that
it comes with all these stickers look at
all these eyeballs oh look at that
honestly this is stressed me out more
than it did before because it is further
personalize this creature I can now see
the stress also who uses tape if you
know someone in high school or college
that uses tape that has an active tape
dispenser it's a [ __ ] psychopath next
oh my gosh multiple things here we go
ready okay this item came up when I
looked at back-to-school supplies and
originally I was like dip wet this is
not a back-to-school supply and then now
in further thinking about the stress and
mental health awareness that we want to
maintain in our youth culture that this
might be the right thing to do it comes
with no explanation two of them are
missing ah this is how I feel about you
all the time just let down I mean fun
cute so this is basically a toy that
it's supposed to be like a fidget
spinner s I couldn't have said it better
myself
they're basically snappy things that you
can push a pee out of the snap pod and
it's supposed to be like a fidget
spinner type esque thing that reduces
stress for you it's a keychain you can
also push peas out of the snap peas as a
nervous reaction to things
nothing says hire me for your internship
like someone in an interview doing this
honestly is kind of satisfying but it's
like a lot I rather just bite my nails q
next what are the cutest back-to-school
accessories is audible have you heard of
them okay cheesy add voice done you guys
know I've been working with audible
forever genuinely enjoy this company
very much to my core which is weird to
say that I have feelings that exist on
that level I don't know what this
cadence is audible is an amazing
resource for audiobooks for original
programming for comedy for news for
entertainment etc and they are allowing
all of you that watch this video of the
chance to try them out free for a month
to go to audible.com slash grace or if
you text grace
seee to 500 500 audible has like an
unmatched library of audible books
available to you not to mention the my
two books Grace's guide and grace and
style voiced by me inaudible but they
also have an insane variety of so many
other things I actually got my mom an
audible account and she is reading the
power of now by Eckhart Tolle in case
you want to indulge in that with her but
the one thing that I am really excited
about right now is big little lies I
know I'm so late to the game
I like binge the entire HBO series the
other day and I loved it so much and I
know it's based on the book and I cannot
wait to listen to the book on audible
and it's available and I'm just saying
in case you wanted I don't know why this
is I don't know why this I'm so rhythmic
with the way I'm expressing everything
that I need to tell you about but
whatever you want to feel the power now
via my mom or you want to hear about big
little lies you know the world is your
oyster if you go to audible.com slash
grace or if you text crazy geraci to
five hundred five hundred that's audible
AUD I BL e.com saturate or text grac
to five hundred five hundred whole month
or free Oh God these are pens but they
are also syringes wow these guys and
they come in a pack of 20 oh yeah you
push the syringe down to get the pen
actually out how subtle and fun oh no
they just write in black and these came
up pretty quickly and I did the Amazon
search for funny back-to-school supplies
so that's curious
each one has like a different actual
colored liquid weird and cute I guess
Wow juice inside of there how do you I
do these what what what is why when does
the bend of what is the why if you are
someone that like finds your insulin
shot hilarious maybe this is something
that you want to investigate yeah
syringe more like sick range oh why are
these common packs of so many as if I
want
more people to own these I thought this
was only one it's a nose
pencil sharpener well this seems like a
before nose when you go to the plastic
surgeon and I show you like we've taken
this to new heights
this feels like one you have to be a kid
that owns a pencil that actually needs
to be sharpened and then to commit to
this scenario this isn't worth it this
is stupid
don't let your kids do this the fun
thing is not have like 15 more to give
out to people find you let me use my
syringe to open this box
I completely forgot about this fun this
was a little bit of a deep dive but I
found something that came up when I
looked up like funny backpacks yeah it's
a fanny pack that looks like a tummy the
great thing about backpacks is they give
you free range of arm movement you can
put them on your back but bad thing
about that tax is that they're causing a
lot of like upper back problems for
young kids so a fanny pack might be it
kind of the new scenario they're very
trendy now especially in the music
festival around feels like they're
making their way into the back to school
supply realm and they're making their
way in a big way you know to be fair a
lot of interior room you can put so many
syringe pens in here upwards of probably
eight to ten nasal pencil sharpeners for
all three of your anxiety it's nappy
situation you can put this Linderman's
anxiety-ridden stepbrother character
inside and you know what it fits like a
glove well there you go there is my
review of back school supplies I hope
you guys enjoyed this if you did give it
a thumbs up let me know what's the most
interesting dumbest funnest thing that
you raise are packing for back-to-school
don't forget to subscribe to this
YouTube channel I make videos I make
videos maybe that's the sentence that we
leave on other than that good luck going
back to school don't worry it only gets
worse I don't know
P snappy snappy snappy snappy snappy
snappy and they give you multiple so you
can make friends if it's like your
freshman year and you want to go through
your dorm room and just be like hey the
last once a weird obvious thing that
totally puts a spotlight on their
anxiety I got two more
[Music]